hey everybody i'm nate from huggingface
and today we have a chat between myself
and dr emily denton a senior research
scientist at google studying the
societal impacts of ai technology and
the conditions of ai development prior
to joining google emily received their
phd in machine learning from nyu where
they focused on unsupervised learning
and generative modeling of images and
video
in this chat we talked about their
transition from working on models to
working on data sets the importance of
taking care when curating and releasing
data sets in ways in which we may in the
future be able to better audit giant
data sets without further ado here's
emily but thank you for being with us
today
thank you for having me really looking
forward to this discussion
yeah um so one of the first things i
always like to ask anybody who's in to
machine learning is how did you end up
in this field
great question
um so i
started out as an undergraduate um in
cognitive science and i was at the
university of toronto and i was really
drawn to cognitive science um i think in
part just through the interdisciplinary
nature of the field so it draws upon
psychology and neuroscience and
philosophy and linguistics and computer
science
and i've always been really drawn to the
kind of cognitive neuroscience side of
things but was really good at like stats
and math so i was like oh what's at all
so i started doing that
and then i got drawn a little bit more
into the kind of computational and like
ai side of the field because i learned
that jeff hinton's lab was there and he
was coming up in all of these cognitive
science texts and i was like oh hey
there's this like great person right
here i could work with and so i ended up
double majoring in cognitive science and
computer science and um had the great
opportunity to work with rich zemel
machine learning lab there um take
classes with jeff hinton um and just
work with all sorts of really great um
folks in that lab as an undergrad so
kind of got into it through that and
then i also think i was sort of in a
little bit of like a i don't know right
place right time kind of situation i was
really interested in neural networks
just before the imagenet 2012 uh
challenge happened and deep learning
boomed and so i
went directly into nyu from an undergrad
i sort of look back and i'm like there's
no way i would have gotten directly in
there a couple of years later but i
snuck in
um just as deep learning was exploding
and uh you know continue to work with
fantastic folks there so that's sort of
like my meandering route into machine
learning
awesome awesome it sounds like an
exciting journey uh uh you know when
when were you uh first learning like
programming then uh if uh
yeah in my i guess like my first year of
undergrad i took a i took a computer
science class never thought i would
major in it um
but it was part of it was part of the
cognitive science curriculum it was like
okay one intro to programming class and
i took that and it turned out i actually
liked it um and then as i got further
into cognitive science they kept
referencing neural networks i was like i
actually want to like understand what a
neural network is and be able to program
one and so i just kind of kept getting
pulled more and more into the computer
science side of things
um and then ended up really enjoying
that as well although now my work has
taken a very different turn and i do
very little programming um and i've
actually kind of like drifted away from
that computational side of things
so so what would be your favorite
programming language then uh uh even
though you're not doing it anymore
python that's all that's like all i ever
reported these days yeah i was gonna i
mean i feel like that was a toss-up
question i think
i think a lot of people in our field is
just kind of an obvious answer um
but
anyway so what sort of things are you
working on these days
yeah so i um continued my like
meandering journey through academic
disciplines um and after i finished my
phd at nyu
i i pretty significantly shifted my
research i joined um the ethical ai team
at google
which at that time was led by meg
mitchell who's at hugging face right now
and timothy gabriel and
i i was really just like compelled by
their vision of ai ethics and this kind
of like you know research paradigm that
they were developing there and they
created a super kind of unique research
environment for me as a fairly junior
researcher and just allowed me to kind
of stretch my own research
collaborate with folks outside of my
formal kind of disciplinary background
and really just develop the kind of
skills required to study the more social
aspects of ai systems um so that's kind
of like where i'm at now studying you
know how they're developed what are
those kinds of work practices that come
to shape how these tools are developed
and then how ai systems intersect with
society and and you know systems of
social inequality in various ways so
that's sort of like at a high level like
where i landed and then just to be like
a little bit more specific with my
current research focus i
um focus a lot on machine learning uh
data sets um so i'm interested in a
whole bunch of different like ethical
dimensions um of machine learning data
sets
um
some things that i i have worked on and
i'm working on relate to the kinds of
values and perspectives that get
embedded in machine learning data sets
um trying to think through like
different stages of development who's
annotating data sets what kind of
perspectives get embedded there you know
how do categories get um constructed
that end up structuring these data sets
and things like that and then what are
you know the kind of implications of all
these decisions um for folks who are
impacted by these models trained from
the data sets
and then i also have some work focused
on a kind of broader set of stakeholders
who are impacted by data set development
um so thinking beyond just people who
are impacted by systems that are
developed but also
data subjects that might be captured in
these data sets or data annotators or
other folks who are laboring on them
and then the final thing that i'm really
interested in and have some ongoing work
on is basically like the social
organization of the field around
benchmark data sets and how data sets
end up being really influential in
structuring research agendas tracking
progress um
and what kind of implications that has
both for the kind of ethics of the field
but also like you know scientific rigor
within the field and things like that so
that's kind of where i'm focusing right
now
right that's that's incredible um
and for folks who are not aware uh
you've sort of made this switch right
because you uh in your earlier work you
were you were working on generative
models more specifically right and then
you sort of um you're through your
journey as i've seen a lot of great
researchers a lot of uh
folks have gone from working on models
directly to to um
uh data sets specifically so can you
talk a little bit about some of your
earlier work
yeah yeah um so earlier work like
pre-that or like how i got into the data
sets focus yeah i i guess just like yeah
what do you had you had started working
on uh with generative models and then
like yeah cause we're gonna mostly talk
about your later research but i think
okay so let me see there's like a little
bit of a narrative here it's always
funny to look back and be like what's
the coherent story so
um my phd focused on generative models
and i was really interested in
generative models in this like fairly
abstract way i would say um i was
interested in
kind of generative like learning
objectives and the ways in which that
could drive um unsupervised or
semi-supervised um
learning methods um and i focused a lot
on images and videos um i think
predominantly just because you know it's
it's nice to like watch a generative
model on images you know you're just
like something clear to look at
um i was also like loosely interested in
kind of you know creative applications
there but i didn't really pursue that
much i was much more focused just on
okay how can we um you know advance our
generative modeling capabilities with
this kind of motivation of like this is
a really rich learning signal so i'd say
that with a lot of my motivation
throughout my phd
um also like a little bit motivated um
in the in the case of like generative
models of videos of thinking about um
like a reinforcement learning paradigm
or some kind of world where you would
want to actually kind of roll out
predictions in some way and then use
that in a planning context so
that was a lot of my motivation there
and then um i became you know kind of
broadly interested in sort of bigger
ethical questions um of ai systems and
one of the first things actually that i
worked on when i joined google so post
phd
kind of you know was this intersection
of ai ethics but also generative models
and so what i did was focused on
building tunable generative models um of
face images where i could take a face
and like add or remove a beard or
lengthen hair or shorten hair and then
use that to kind of probe
a facial analysis system and you know
get a sense of like oh if i you know add
or remove a beard while keeping
everything else equal does that change
um the prediction that the system makes
assuming the prediction should be
independent of facial hair so i was
looking at like a smiley markiplier so
that's one of the things that i worked
on initially but i started to realize
that there's all sorts of like ethical
dimensions even of that kind of paradigm
of work i started to really you know
kind of interrogate um
different kinds of categories that get
embedded into our ai ethics frameworks
you know how are we defining gender how
are we defining race race didn't come up
in this particular example but that's a
big category that some of my work um
later work started to focus on
and so you know other broader questions
about like you know what are the ethics
of just evaluating facial analysis
systems when that is a class of
technology that in and of itself um
raises a whole set of ethical questions
even beyond just you know looking at
model performance in an isolated context
so
that was sort of my first step towards
more ai ethics focused research and i
realized that i was actually interested
in a lot of these like deeper social
questions
that were less technical in nature and
so that kind of brought me
um to another project that focused on
really interrogating the categories that
were underlying ai ethics and
algorithmic fairness work and that was a
collaboration with a sociologist um alex
hannah
and she's somebody who i continue to
collaborate with and have just like
learned learned so much from um like i
really seek out collaborations with
folks who like have a different
disciplinary background and this has
just been one of the like most
incredible um collaborative
relationships that i think i've built
post phd i've just learned so much from
her and that collaboration actually
brought me to data so i'm gonna i'm
gonna land this this story i promise um
but we started talking basically about
our respective fields and how
how data was treated in our respective
fields so how she is a sociologist
approach to data and how i as a machine
learning researcher had approached data
and you know we just realized that there
were just you know completely different
approaches and valuations of data even
though they're both very data-heavy
fields right so in sociology it's
totally expected that you go out and you
collect a data set and you invest a huge
amount of time and labor and care into
developing this data set you think
really deeply about what categories are
going to structure the data how are you
going to measure different social
constructs and in machine learning it's
you know you know it's like a little bit
more of a free-for-all you know it's
like available what's cheap
let's scrape the entire internet right
exactly exactly exactly like oh let's
just pull categories from somewhere you
know but it's like this data like is
it's it's this infrastructure that
underlies everything we do and so it was
conversations like that that brought us
both to kind of studying um data in
machine learning um from that particular
perspective so that's uh yeah that's my
you know sort of journey there
no it's awesome to hear your journey
because you know i think we all are kind
of like iterating towards what that
thing is that we're really passionate
about and it's nice to hear that you
know
uh you know what things you were
passionate about and how they they
brought you to where you are today so i
think it's really important to get that
context which is why i asked to hear um
some of that that earlier stuff but
anyways um uh you know now now we're
here now we've landed on uh
sort of um ai ethics and things like
that um uh
especially centering around data and so
one model are a couple of models that
have that have kind of uh come out this
past week that are um that have you know
taken data sets that are basically
taking the entire internet are our palm
from google and and open ai's dolly too
and in opening eyes case uh they
continue to kind of choose to keep these
models closed source
citing issues around potential misuse
and abuse of these models which is
obviously uh a huge consideration
because um you know if they scrape the
entire internet these models are going
to end up and they do text text to image
you're going to end up having the
potential for serious
abuse um so as you see it do you think
there is a potentially maybe a better
way to release these models um
while keeping these considerations or is
this just the way it has to be
yeah so this is this is a great question
um i think there's definitely like no
universal answer
um and i certainly don't have you know
like a perfect answer but i think like
you know you've identified these kind of
opposing tensions right like on one hand
there's huge value in open sourcing
models and making them open to
interrogation by the public i think
it's a really really good example that i
come to a lot in different talks um it
kind of highlights the value of this
sort of open sourcing so there's this
team within google and they develop a
tool um called perspective api
and this is an open source tool and it
aids in content moderation um it's
basically a
toxicity classification model that takes
in a piece of text and rates it on a
level of toxicity
and um i bring this up because
this is a really fantastic example of
the value of open sourcing models so
they have a really long history of
taking their tool putting it online and
having all sorts of people use that tool
and uncover like a wide range of really
problematic behavior
and you know posting it online tweeting
about it writing blog posts about it um
and in a sense like the public has kind
of become part of their like adversarial
testing framework and of course it's
like yes in a perfect world the tool
wouldn't have any of these problems but
also like that's not the world that we
live in um and so
it's been really valuable for them to
like have this tool out and to have
people probe it
something that's really nice is that
they've been really open to these sorts
of critiques
and um like really responsive to them as
well so releasing new models developing
new data sets and methods to like
address these gaps and address the
potential harms that people have
identified and so you know there's many
more examples but i think that's just
like such a clear example of like if
this tool
um you know was not open and available
for people there's all sorts of you know
potential like risks of harm and kind of
gaps in the ways in which it's developed
that just like would not be uncovered
of course on the other hand very serious
you know risks of misuse that obviously
wasn't a generative model but you
identified like all sorts of um you know
risks that can come along with
generative models
and so i think like you know one
one natural way of addressing this is to
kind of think about
you know something in between you know
not releasing anything and releasing
everything in full right like thinking
through um you know really careful terms
of use that a model might be released
under um and this would involve you know
the developers of a model really really
thinking through like what is the
landscape of potential misuse what is
the landscape of potential harms that
could result from this model um and then
you know maybe performing some kind of
impact assessment involving different
stakeholders to like really really map
this out and then developing some kind
of relief strategy in terms of use that
is based on that and so it could be
um you know this model is open to
um you know be evaluated and tested in
some way shape or form but it's not open
to just use in whatever manner you want
so i think something like that would be
really good um
obviously i think this is still a pretty
open area of research like what would um
appropriate kind of licensing models
look like in this case i think there's
there's still a lot of open questions
there but that is i think the direction
that would be really good for the field
to kind of be considering that kind of
sort of strikes a balance between you
know the benefits and risks that come
along with releasing models
right right yeah for me i think one of
the more important things is is just
being able to get a diverse group of
people to probe the model um
because you know an institution that
releases or like that has a close source
model that is using it you know uh if
it's up to them to choose the people to
that get to use it i think that you know
you know you might not end up getting
the most diverse group of folks uh yeah
that's that's always kind of been my
thing i'm considering
but yeah
anyways um so yeah let's get to some of
your your your um
more more recent work so in one recent
paper from last year um data in its
discontents a survey of data set
development and use in machine learning
research yourself and your co-authors
discuss ways that we can better design
collect maintain and distribute machine
learning data sets
for those people who haven't read this
paper can you talk a little bit about
this work and what sort of
considerations we should be taking when
putting together future data sets
yeah so this
is a really fun paper to work on because
it was a survey paper so it just
involved all of us reading all sorts of
different papers that we're talking
about various concerns and kind of
synthesizing them and putting forward
this particular narrative and broadly
speaking
the papers that we focused on all
discussed
different sorts of limitations of the
predominant data practices that you know
kind of characterize the field of
machine learning and so we covered
different aspects in the paper um one
section of the paper really focuses on
the kind of pipeline of data set
development so looking at you know data
set design collection documentation
release maintenance
things like that and you know one of the
key findings there was just that there's
a
kind of a lack of any sort of
standardized method um so um up until a
couple of years ago um there was no sort
of standardized frameworks of data set
documentation this is something where
we're now seeing a lot of frameworks in
the past couple of years come out um but
that's fairly recent um same thing if
you look at all these different stages
it's like there's not a clear you know
kind of methodology that people are
following and things are done in a
fairly haphazard way um and not
necessarily um you know kind of embedded
with the kind of care that we might want
to see given how fundamental data is in
the field
and then we also summarized some
findings of recent data set audits that
have been performed and we looked at
audits that
um you know kind of uncovered concerning
or problematic um characteristics of
different data sets in the field so
things like
skus towards western image sources
in computer vision data sets
skews towards lighter skin subjects and
facial analysis data sets um various
sorts of social biases and stereotypes
that get embedded in text and image data
sets things like this so just kind of
synthesizing all of the different
outputs of these data set audits um and
then
we also kind of took a step back and
looked at um what we kind of called like
data cultures within the field and this
was focusing less on specific data sets
and more
like what is the field's relationship to
data kind of like what i was talking
about um you know my conversations with
my sociologist collaborator so how are
people thinking about data um and we
drew here on some work that's um
examined a kind of widespread
underevaluation of data work um across
the field of machine learning
we also talk a little bit about the
kind of hyper focus on soda chasing like
state of the art chasing
um and also talk a little bit about um
you know the ways in which that kind of
mode of doing research coupled with the
fact that you know data sets are always
limited and always embed artifacts can
kind of lead people to kind of gain
these benchmarks and things like that
so so that is um that's the kind of like
main findings of the paper um a lot of
our recommendations really just focus on
embedding care in different aspects of
data set development we cite all sorts
of different frameworks that have come
out in recent years so documentation
frameworks
kind of accountability frameworks
data set analysis tools we also cite a
bunch of those because there's a bunch
of really cool tools that have come out
in recent years that can enable
um data set developers and data set
consumers to really like interrogate
their data a little bit better and get a
sense of like what's in there um and
then also thinking about you know how as
a field we can kind of shift the
valuation of data work um and it's
pretty interesting because this is a
paper you know we wrote it i guess in
2020
or yeah i think 2020 um
and
you know the field is actually shifting
really fast i think we are seeing a lot
of cultural shifts um nurips this year
had a new track focused on data sets and
benchmarks and that's like i think just
such an incredible um step forward in
terms of okay how do we incentivize
careful data work how do we really start
to value this kind of work within the
field um we're starting to see
like transparency requirements be
integrated into different like reviewing
guidelines and submission guidelines
we're seeing you know hugging face and
other kinds of you know like online like
data set and model repositories like
really foregrounding transparency which
i think also kind of shifts the ways in
which folks in the field are thinking
about these things so this is a really
interesting paper because it's very much
like cool what's everything wrong with
the field and so it's nice to look at it
and be like okay where like where's the
dial moving a little bit and where are
we starting to see shifts um so i think
that's that's kind of a cool lens to
look at it now and it's only been a
couple of years
right i mean i think i think this stuff
has been hugely transformative for our
our whole field and it's and it's
obvious you can see it like this this
past year uh like there used to be so
little conversation around ai ethics
like in general
you know in papers or online and things
like that and now it's it's at the
forefront of the conversation which i
think is super important because we want
to make sure that you know
uh you know we had hugging face and also
the the entire uh machine learning
landscape everybody's pushing good
machine learning because i think that's
you know that's what's good for the
world right
um
now
uh another question i want to ask so
around data sets i feel like no matter
what we do for these very very large
data sets um in terms of risk
minimization there's always like a
chance that we're going to end up with a
data set containing um personally
identifiable information um potentially
harmful images etc and so one thing i've
been thinking a little bit about is the
idea of like a live data set so
something where you know you share the
data set and then as people identify
pii or anything like that people can
flag those examples and the data set
kind of updates live and people are
always downloading the the version that
has the least amount of harmful
examples in it do you think something
like this could work or is the fact that
it's to
constantly changing a little bit too
frustrating the scientific community in
terms of uh computing benchmarks paper
to paper
yeah so i also i love this line of
thought i have some thoughts here
they're definitely not like fully baked
um so you know being either it's all
good
um but i love i think the idea of like a
live data set is super compelling and it
is
so it relates to a concept that i've
explored with some of my collaborators
in
kind of a project that we've called
genealogies of data and um a workshop
paper that brings this concept up a
little bit um but it's mostly just like
we've like chatted about a bunch and
it's basically the idea of
contestability so what would it look
like to incorporate contestability as a
data set design principle and so there's
already some existing work that focuses
on contestability of algorithmic systems
where the term contestability here often
refers to the ability of somebody to
challenge or oppose a decision so if
somebody is
um i don't know like not granted alone
by some automated decision making system
to design contestability in would allow
them to kind of contest and challenge
this um
and you could also imagine expanding
this concept um to enable like users or
stakeholders to challenge different
aspects of design um empower people a
little bit more rather than just this
final decision point
but more generally i think it's really
interesting to think about like what
would contestability look like as a data
set design principle right like what are
the different points of contestation in
a data set um what kinds of mechanisms
of control what might we build in for
different stakeholders including data
subjects um to kind of enable shaping
and controlling the data set and
there's you know there's obviously like
a ton of different components of this
like transparency is one aspect of it
right you can't really empower people to
you know remove their image from a data
set or ask to have it removed if they
have no idea that they're going to be
represented in a data set to begin with
um so i think there's like a lot of
steps that would come before actually
kind of fully having this kind of model
but i think that's a really really
interesting um lens basically to kind of
be exploring um
this aspect and also it kind of comes
back to that point you know you were
making before about open sourcing models
and like allowing a broader set of
stakeholders to like probe and challenge
models right it's sort of like what if
we you know did something similar with a
data set um and and enabled people who
probably have you know different
perspectives and different backgrounds
and different kind of orientations to
that particular data set to really like
probe it test it you know say actually
this is like a really problematic
representation or maybe it's just like
hey my image is in here i don't want my
image
you know like
a broad range of things
so so yeah i think that's um like a
really really fascinating um you know
kind of uh direction of thought
um yeah thanks thanks for kind of going
down that rabbit hole with me because
that's an idea i've been thinking about
for a while i just i'm not sure exactly
how uh what the next steps forward are
uh
yeah
um so i know we're running close to out
of time um
i suppose one question i think is is
interesting is uh well actually i'll
just jump into the last questions here i
don't want to keep you too long
um so when you're not working on ai
research you know what sort of things do
you like to do for fun
oh good question um
i i'd say i have two main well a couple
hobbies i i do aerial circus um so
it's kind of like acrobatics hanging on
a thing in the air uh a bit of a weird
hobby but it's also like there's a ton
of people in new york who do it so
that's that's a lot of what i do um and
then i also i rock climb um i got really
into rock climbing during the pandemic
um
inside outside love it it's fantastic um
and
i'm also
i'd say
very crafty uh this is also my diy
habits have uh
definitely
uh
seen an uptick during the pandemic so
just like i don't know making
macrame plant holders and jam and
sauerkraut and
basically if there's a thing that i
could like make instead of buying it um
often try and air towards that um
and making like i don't know sort of
lopsided pillows and things for my house
everything's like a little lopsided but
like
hey that's that's how you know that you
made it that's how you know that your
hands were on it that's you know that's
the beauty of making things at home
right exactly exactly yeah i think i
like really really leaned into that
during the pandemic um which was a good
use of time um i think uh i haven't
really like developed any particularly
like like i'm not very good at any of
the crafting stuff that i do you know i
do it a lot i enjoy it well you don't
need to be professional it's something
you want to just have fun with so it's
fine
anyways emily thank you so much for
taking the time to chat with me today i
really uh this is a great conversation
so uh yeah on behalf of everybody that's
watching and and my stuff i just want to
thank you so awesome yeah thanks so much
lovely talking with you